So, here is the resources directory from
a sample project created in an Android
studio.
There are some predefined
drawable folders for
different screen densities such as mdpi,
hdpi, xhdpi, and xxhdpi.
And if you remember that's 160,
240, 320, and 480.
Additionally, there's a drawable
folder with no qualifier.
This is useful for
things like XML shapes.
There's also a folder called
Drawable-nodpi which you can put in
images that shouldn't scale based on
density, things like background images.
If you remember from Android
fundamentals, there are also qualifiers
for user locale, screen width,
API level, and more.
These can be applied to
any type of resource,
whether it'd be graphic assets,
layouts, or text strings and
style definitions that you would
put in your values folder.
So you could customize a layout for
screens that are 600dp or wider.
Or you could provide styles that
only apply to Lollipop devices,
that's devices with API level 21 or
higher.
And if you wanted to customize graphics
assets for specific languages,
you could do that, too.
Just remember to also specify
the density for those assets.
Check the instructor's notes for
a link to developers.android.com and
a listing of the accepted
resource identifiers.